mâcon qui appelle donc à retrouver
l'esprit de l'accord de paris mais quel
bilan écologistes pour le chef d'état
français depuis son fameux discours qui
lui a valu le titre de champion de la
terre par l'onu en 2018 c'est l'heure de
notre décryptage
nous pour en parler ce soir charles de
la con membres du conseil fédéral des
amis de la terre en direct avec nous
bonsoir kevin goût et analyste en
stratégie environnementale cofondateur
de l'association on the green global
project bonsoir et merci à vous d'être
en direct avec nous sur ce plateau pour
la partie un peu plus internationale
puisque évidemment c'est toute la
planète qui est représenté régis le
sommier grand reporter rt france bonsoir
régissent le succès de l'aco 26 est à
portée de main a dit emmanuel macron si
nous nous mobilisons décidons et
agissons à la portée de main vraiment
c'est aussi simple que ça le passé nous
l'a pas franchement démontrer régis non
puisque déjà on sait ce qui s'est passé
donc là les accords de paris les etats
unis se sont retirés avec fracas on s'en
souvient c'était le premier acte du
gouvernement trucks de sortir de ce
cadre il y avait déjà des commandes et
des objectifs qui sont un peu similaires
qui avaient été fixés au moment de la
coop 21 et au moment de la commentaires
il y avait une sorte d' enthousiasme à
lorsqu on note aujourd'hui c'est que un
certain nombre de leaders internationaux
joe biden emmanuel macron essaie de le
re suscité cet enthousiasme emmanuel
macron je pense je joue une partition du
bon élève de la classe dans là dedans
dans la mesure où la france n'est qu'au
12e rang des pays les plus pollueurs du
monde et que le nucléaire lui a permis
justement d'éviter des maîtres du
dioxyde de carbone comme la plupart des
grands pays industriels donc la france a
choisi une politique énergétique
différentes et qui la met un petit peu à
l'abri je dirais 2 deux de ces critiques
donc emmanuel macron essaye aujourd'hui
d'apparaître un leader dans cette en ce
domaine alors qu'on le sait au niveau du
g20 ça n'a pas été tout à fait comment
la grande réconciliation avec les états
unis et emmanuel macron justement et c
est apparu comme un peu je dirai comment
toujours humilié et la france toujours
humilié par le parent par le géant
américain
google
lancé en réponse à donald trump a un qui
avait décidé vous l'avez dit régis de
quitter la corde de paris c'est resté
dans la mémoire y compris à l'étranger
mais emmanuel macron en france on est
très critiquée par les écologistes
charles de la conque vous attendez tout
de même quelque chose du président
français pour ce nouveau rendez-vous
aujourd'hui je pense que c'est difficile
de dire qu'on attend encore vraiment
quelque chose de lui dans son discours
tout à l'heure je les regarde et il a
parlé d' ambition alors que lui la seule
qu'il a pour le climat c'est de jeter
toujours plus de technologie pour
essayer de résoudre le problème il a
parlé de solidarité alors que finalement
les mesures sont toujours pas prises
pour accompagner les pays du sud qui
sont les plus exposés au dérèglement
climatique par notre faute finalement à
tous les pays occidentaux du nord
l'union européenne la russie les
etats-unis ont une grosse dette
climatique vis-à-vis de ces pays là et
ne font rien concrètement aujourd'hui
pour les aider il ya eu beaucoup de
critiques à l'égard de la com 26
d'ailleurs puisque c'est aussi des pays
qui sont très touchés par le cos vide
qui ont difficilement pu s'organiser
pour venir participer bref et enfin il a
parlé de confiance il a dit qu'il
fallait rétablir la confiance avec les
citoyens faire plus de transparence et
c'est difficile de dire ça depuis sa
position alors que ça fait quatre ans
lui qu'il est à la tête de l'état un des
principaux est une des principales
puissances du g20 et qu'il a fait
l'inversé de ce qu'il a dit en fait tout
ce qu'il y avait dans son discours était
vraiment été oui était vraiment l'
inverse de ce qu'il a fait pendant ces
quatre ans à la tête de la france alors
il a été quand même ambitieux ans il a
appelé notamment à plus d'engagement
pour revenir aux 1,5 degré comme espéré
lors de l'accord de paris dont il veut
retrouver
esprit at il dit mais c'est vrai que la
france un souvent kevin boyer critiqué
pour faire pression pour que le gaz est
nucléaire soit soit propre c'est pas
vraiment le choix des écologistes
il faut savoir que si l'on peut parler
vraiment d'énergie il faut comprendre
que le nucléaire c'est entre ligne et
l'énergie qui nous permet de décarbonés
notre
notre système économique actuel
par contre le nucléaire n'est pas une
solution écologique et le gaz c'est très
émetteurs de co2 le pétrole encore plus
et les charbons encore plus qui est la
principale source de production
électrique en france en parlant de
france excusé pour ce faire
il est important de comprendre quels
sont les enjeux qui sont les nôtres
beaucoup de monde car le climat il est
essentiel de comprendre qu'il n'ya pas
que des enjeux de climat il ya aussi des
enjeux liés à la biodiversité
la première
cause de l'est la sixième extinction de
masse de l'activité une aide et ça
arrive rien à voir avec les différents
enjeux climatiques
on voit notamment que par exemple la
surpêche créé qu'il ya une disparition
des coraux qui a une disparition de la
plupart des espèces comme les dauphins
et les baleines et plein d'autres noms
de poissons et des petites espèces qui
sont présents partout
moi quand j'entends par là qu on mélange
un petit peu tous leurs deux de ces
coques 26 et que c'est pas vraiment
lisible
exactement ça et pour avoir pu
participer l'iucn qui est l'équivalent
de la coop mais version de diversité il
faut bien comprendre que quand
on va retrouver kevin goût et dans
quelques instants la connexion est en
mauvaise régis le sommier vous parliez
tout à l'heure vous évoquiez joe biden
rapidement le président américain qui
s'est excusé on l'a vu auprès des
dirigeants pour le retrait des états
unis de l'accord de paris il a qualifié
la lutte contre le réchauffement
d'opportunités incroyable pour
l'économie mondiale tout va changer avec
le sauveur maiden non pas du tout là on
est encore dans une forme d'hypocrisie
puisque les américains sont les
principaux pollueurs mondiaux la chine
arrive derrière donc les américains
émettent environ 20% du dioxyde de
carbone dans l'atmosphère la chine est à
11 la russie et l'inde étaient juste
après la russie en ensuite viennent ne
viennent ensuite le brésil et quelques
autres pays comme l'indonésie mais donc
là la grande hypocrisie des aides des
états unis c'est de dire effectivement
on va miser sur des technologies
nouvelles ce que tout le discours de
bail des reds revenaient à dire
finalement que on allait créer des
emplois en ayant une attitude
écologistes en ayant en transformant
finalement l'industrie et que les états
unis allaient y arriver certes ils ont
les capacités technologiques on sait
qu'ils sont très en avance là-dessus
mais néanmoins les états unis restent
encore un pays dont
25% entre 20 et 25% de l'électricité est
produite par le charbon ces deux aux
états unis vous avez encore des
accidents de grisou comme en pologne
jeudi on est dans ce genre de vous allez
dans les alpes dans les appalaches vous
avez encore ce type de mine donc les
états unis dire oui on va comment tous
s'y mettent et on va arriver à ce
comment ce but de 1,5 degré à la fin du
siècle lui signale qu entre parenthèses
une étude des nations unies de septembre
place plutôt l'augmentation le
réchauffement climatique à 2 27 degrés
et on est loin des 1,5 annoncé par
emmanuel macron donc je dire la grande
transformation que nous promet byden de
l'industrie américaine va prendre
énormément de temps et encore une fois
c'est principal pollueur au monde
aujourd'hui sont des cons quand on
entend effectivement emmanuel macron
nous dire yaka il suffit de si on est
mobilisé si on prend l'air les décisions
qui s'imposent sauf que là comme vient
nous le rappelle régis le sommier il est
sur une envie sont de 5 degrés alors que
l'onu comme vous l'avez dit un parent
d'un réchauffement catastrophique de 2,7
degrés à la fin du siècle
qu'est ce qu'on doit faire pour y
arriver parce que tous les toutes les
critiques voilà ont l'air de dire que
tout les coptes qui s'enchaînent ne
donne jamais de beaucoup de résultats
pardon
pour pour clarifier
le 1,5 degré c'est l'objectif qui a été
acté dans les accords de paris c'est le
seuil à ne pas dépasser et si on
n'arrive pas à ne pas dépasser les 1,5
degré ça ne pas dépasser les 2 degrés et
si on fait la somme des engagements qui
ont été pris par les états pour
respecter l'accord de paris c'est là où
on arrive actuellement à plus de 17
degrés donc déjà on a des des objectifs
des engagements qui sont insuffisants et
en plus les ai pas en fait ne respectent
pas leurs engagements et la france pas
plus que les autres ce qui fait que on
est parti même pour dépasser ses plus de
7 degrés d'ici la fin du siècle donc là
c'est quand même quelque chose qui est
assez catastrophique là dessus ça veut
pas dire que le processus des coques est
inutile et qu'il faudrait pas le faire
puisque la crise climatique c'est un
problème global qui appelle évidemment
une réponse globale mais simplement
sondés sont des processus qui ne sont
pas qui ne permettent pas qui ne sont
pas contraignants qui ne permettent pas
d'obtenir des garanties fortes de la
part des états et c'est aussi pour ça
qu'on a qu'on a besoin d'une
mobilisation citoyenne très forte c'est
pour ça que la mort aujourd'hui où elle
est mais quelle est la qualité un petit
peu déplorable de ma vidéo c'est parce
que je suis dans les rues de glasgow ce
matin je sais une action citoyenne avec
le collectif action non violente comme
21 pour dénoncer le double discours des
dirigeants est particulièrement emmanuel
macron pour montrer que la société
civile et mobiliser la société civile
n'est pas dupe des mensonges elle voit
que macro et parc emmanuel macron est un
pompier pyromane et on est là pour
mettre la pression pour forcer les états
à respecter un engagement qu'on
maintenant puisqu'on parle de nos
conditions d'existence tout simplement
kevin goût et vous vous partagez ce
diagnostic parce que c'est ce qui
revient souvent aussi une forme
d'hypocrisie et de et de double discours
de la part des dirigeants et notamment
celui d'ailleurs de d'emmanuel macro
je le partage totalement et j'irai même
plus loin un exemple concret qui montre
cette hypocrisie
c'est la convention citoyenne pour le
climat moi je travaille au quotidien que
les 150 citoyens de la convention
citoyenne qu'on fait un travail mais
hors norme et
malgré le maquereau hors mis à part
avoir fait de l'acquisition politique
avec ses 140 de propositions il y aurait
sorti une loi climat qui n'est pas
nouveau climat qui est une loi
pour faire beau voilà tout simplement
qu' une loi qui est là pour faire faire
beau dans le paysage politique et pour
dire oui moi monsieur emmanuel macron je
réponds à vos enjeux climatiques
pour avoir parlé avec bruno le maire et
emmanuel macron partage exactement le
même principe
il n'ya pas longtemps leurs demis
transition forum j'ai pu voir avec eux
quelle est l'essence même de qu'ailleurs
vision visé l'environnement pour
l'environnement c'est un problème et ce
au problème ils le traitent en dix ans
la technologie c'est ça qui sauvera le
monde il faut savoir que les grandes
entreprises comme veolia total énergie
et c'est
la même vision
emmanuel macron n'est autre qu'un
entrepreneur
d'une nation dirige une nation qu'elle
c'était une entreprise on ne peut pas
diriger une nation comme ça une
entreprise et les intrus qui est
essentielle et que je voulais dire tout
à l'heure avant que ça bug désolé pour
betclic
emmanuel par macro on parle d'écologie
je vous invite vous médias a interrogé
emmanuel macron sur ce qu'est l'écologie
il ne sera même pas définir concrètement
alors tenir l'appareil manuel macro qui
vous donne pas crédita sion pour aller
lui parler donc régis le sommier sur 7
sur cette hypocrisie alors c'est rigolo
parce que ils sont pas tous venus en
bateau à voile c'est cher dirigeant à
glasgow surtout autour d'eux des des
dirigeants il ya un certain nombre de
milices de ce qu'on peut appeler les
milliardaires vert c'est-à-dire des jeff
des os et autres qui sont eux arrivés
avec leur jet privé un des autres sa
prison gulfstream voilà flambant neuf et
alors ce qui est intéressant parce que
la presse anglaise évidemment s'est
emparé de cette histoire puisqu'il ya
environ 400 avions privés 400 jet privé
qui sont arrivés oui ce fait beaucoup
mais pour la alors j'ai noté c'est le
daily mail qui publie sa pour la journée
d'hier plein seule journée d'hier
l'aéroport de glasgow a été donc
accueilli 52 jet privé et ça émis dans
l'atmosphère 13000 tonnes de dioxyde de
carbone soit l'équivalent de ce
qu'émettent 1600 anglais en un an voilà
ils vont faire une petite comparaison
pour montrer que ces gens effectivement
400 avions privés pour venir à une coop
on est on essaye justement de réduire
des émissions de gaz et de bon voilà et
ont alors bon il le prince charles a
également utilisé un jet à rubis s'est
il a dit oui mais j'utilise un carburant
du rap d'aviation qui respecte etc etc
le prince albert aussi à utiliser son
vient de priver ces gens là pourrait
peut-être déjà voyager sur des vols
commerciaux et on sait aussi qu'un
certain nombre de délégués
malheureusement de moins nantis sont
restés en rade et n'ont pas pu venir
parce qu'il ya eu des intempéries le pr
pensé prendre le train donc un moyen de
transport nettement moins polluants
voilà alors l'état français charles de
la combat qui a on le rappelle aussi le
mois dernier été condamnés dans le cadre
de la sphère du siècle on rappelle pour
ceux qui avaient oublié quatre
organisations d'intérêt général qui ont
assigné l'état français en justice
devant le tribunal administratif de
paris pour inaction face au changement
climatique donc état français condamné
c'est là encore le double discours que
l'on voit aujourd'hui à glasgow
oui absolument donc effectivement vous
faites bien mentionné il ya eu cette
condamnation par le tribunal
administratif
il ya également eu une autre
condamnation un peu plus tôt dans
l'année par le conseil d'état cette fois
suite à un recours de la cour de la
commune de grande synthe pour nom
protection de l'état restent non
protection des habitants et des français
face aux dérèglements climatiques encore
une autre condamnation du conseil d'état
pour inaction face à la pollution de
l'air donc effectivement on est sur un
on est sur un état qui est condamné
trois fois par les paras part des plus
hautes instances de la république
française c'est assez assez terrible et
pour pour revenir sur ce qu'on disait de
soleure et pour aller plus loin
effectivement on l'a on est plus sur
deux de l'inaction on est sur un
véritable sabotage climatique en fait
puisque non seulement il
ya le l'inaction et le
qui devrait faire n'est pas dépassé il
devrait de fait n'est pas fait mais on a
des discours qui sont lénifiant en
dormant qui empêche de bouger qui font
croire que la france est leader etc et
en plus il ya un soutien absolument
délétère had à des entreprises vous avez
mentionné jeff bezos amazon par exemple
c'est une entreprise qui est largement
soutenue par emmanuel macron dans le
cadre de la loi climat avec les amis de
la terre on a on a failli faire passer
on avait convaincu plein de député de la
république en marge de faire passer des
mesures pour endiguer l'expansion
d'amazones qui non seulement détruit les
emplois mais en plus cause de la de la
surconsommation et de la surproduction
qui n'est pas du tout cohérent avec des
trajectoires qu'on devrait avoir
emmanuel macron c'est également des
soutiens sans faille à total par exemple
qui a des projets extrêmement
problématique de palpable de pipeline à
la fois en ouganda à la fois en arctique
donc voilà c'est vraiment cette notion
de sabotage et il ne fait pas il dit
qu'il fait et en même temps il fait l
inverse de ce qu il faudrait faire un
dernier mot registre clan ce décryptage
est évidemment l'absence très commenté
et critiqué de la chine et de la russie
en tout cas sur place à glasgow oui
absence mais qui est donc à chaque fois
justifié dans un cas comme dans l'autre
puisque xiji pin olsen âge ne s'est même
pas déplacé que depuis deux 2 chine
depuis
l'année dernière depuis le début de la
pandémie donc ça il ya une raison et le
résurgence justement du coc vide en
chine non c'est l'explication qui a été
donné on sait qu'il a suivie par
visioconférence le g20 tout en envoyant
au yang jiechi et son ministre des
affaires étrangères parlées et comment
justement là sur les d d'autres affaires
internationales avec ses partenaires la
sur la question la russie il n'y a pas
vraiment d'explication c'est simplement
que le porte parole du kremlin dimitri
peskov lui a exprimé clairement que la
russie s'était engagé à réduire ses
émissions de dioxyde de carbone d'ici
2050 de 80% et également à abandonner
progressivement le charbon au profit du
nucléaire donc la russie montre qu'elle
est là pendant la coop 21 l'époque de la
coop 21 vladmir poutine avait elle fait
le déplacement à paris pour ce sommet du
climat merci résistance sommiers merci
également à vous charles de lacombe et
kevin agout et d'avoir été en direct
assure rt france